[Musique]
bon sens à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour cette nouvelle édition de
présidentielle 360 voici les titres
fin du suspense pour les candidats aux
législatives la république en marche les
noms de 428 personnalité issue en partie
de la société civile ont été dévoilées
ils doivent incarner le renouvellement
manuel valls n'a pas été investi mais
n'aura pas de ma chronique face à lui à
trois jours de la passation de pouvoir
entre françois hollande et manuel macro
que retenir du quinquennat on fera le
bilan politique sociale et économique de
ce que devait être une présidence
normale
on s'intéressera aussi à hollande chef
de guerre avec mes invités faire un
report des élections sénatoriales évoqué
hier l'hypothèse précise un report d'un
an permettrait au nouveau président de
la république d'appliquer rapidement la
diminution du nombre de parlementaires
le détail dans cette édition
et je vous rappelle que vous pouvez
réagir à cette émission sur twitter avec
le hashtag présidentielle 360 pour
m'accompagner cet après midi sa verrière
ogec en direct de la salle des
conférences du sénat
le multiplexe et tout de suite
[Musique]
428 candidat de la république en marche
pour les législatives ils sont issus de
l'ensemble du spectre politique
républicain 52 % viennent de la société
civile c'est ce qu'a annoncé et richard
ferrand le secrétaire général de la
république en marchant l'écoutent au
total ce sont dix neuf mille dossiers de
candidatures qui ont été déposés sur la
plateforme depuis le 19 janvier
sans compter l'afflux de quelques
milliers ces derniers jours en moyenne
en moyenne qui ne sont donc pas prises
en compte vous l'aurez compris dans les
statistiques
aujourd'hui ce sont cinquante deux pour
cent des candidates et des candidats qui
sont issus de la société civile au sens
qu'ils n'ont jamais exercé de mandat
électif et qu'il n'exerce aujourd'hui
aucun mandat politique sur la parité
réelle
deux cent quatorze candidats sont des
femmes
214 sont des hommes de sorte que vous
aurez compris que ce sont 400 28
candidats dont qui sont compris dans la
liste qui vous sera fournie et on va
tout de suite retrouvé un autre
journaliste cécile 6 où vous êtes devant
le qg et bien d' emmanuel macron où les
candidats ont été présentés pour ces
législatives
et il y avait un coeur qui suscite l
attention des journalistes c'est le cas
valls alors on sait qu'il n'y aura pas
deux candidats macro nist face à lui
pour ces élections
mais il n'est pas non plus investi la
république en marche oui alors comme
vous venez de l'entendre 1 delphine 428
candidats ont été investis pour la
république en marche manuel valls ne
fait pas partie de la liste
richard ferrand a expliqué qu'il ne
répondait pas aux critères car il a déjà
fait trois mandats parlementaires mais
comme manuel valls est une personnalité
la commission a choisi de ne pas mettre
de candidat face à lui
et on écoute et j'affirme nous avons
constaté le président de la commission
nationale d'investiture n'a confirmé que
la candidature de l'intéressé ne
répondait pas aux critères puisque l'un
d'entre eux prévoient qu'il ne faut
qu'un candidat ne peut être investi s'il
a déjà effectué trois mandats de
parlementaire donc est la règle est
connue depuis le 19 janvier
cela étant nous estimons que au moment
où nous voulons rassembler largement ne
pas donner l'impression du millier de
rejeter d'être dans une vindicte qui
pourrait être lui du moins par vous même
ou par d'autres et bien à ce stade nous
ne resterons pas de candidate ou le
candidat donc nous n'investissons pas
l'intéresser mais nous ne lui oppose ont
pas a priori de candidates et de prendre
alors sur les ça si on fait le calcul
delphine sur les 577 circonscriptions et
le reste 148 à pourvoir
richard ferrand a d'abord expliqué qu'il
voulait laisser le temps à certains élus
notamment aux républicains qui ont
déclaré vouloir aider le président de
manifester leur candidature l'autre
explication c'est que dans certaines
circonscriptions
le mouvement pourrait ne pas placer deux
candidats comme c'est le cas pour manuel
valls pour laisser plus de chance à des
candidats qui voudraient participer à la
majorité présidentielle
on pense notamment à gilles boyer ou à
bruno le maire voilà en tout cas
mercredi prochain on aura à la liste
définitive de tous les candidats
merci beaucoup cécile pour toutes ces
précisions vous étiez avec quentin
calmer sur place et on continue les
réactions politiques à cette
présentation des candidats aux
législatives avec nicole bricq sénatrice
soutient emmanuel macron qui était il ya
quelques instants au micro de ses
verrières ogec nicole bricq
on marche a donc dévoilé une grande
partie de ces investitures tout à
l'heure est-ce que tout d'abord vous
regrettez les psychodrames qui ont
entouré ce processus et je pense en
particulier bien évidemment au cas de
manuel valls
d'abord c'est la deuxième étape celle du
renouvellement
des têtes et en même temps le renouveau
de la vie politique au niveau des
méthodes de travail et je pense que
richard ferrand le secrétaire général du
mouvement en marche a bien rectifié le
tir dans le respect de ce qu'est manuel
valls l'ancien premier ministre de la
france et par rapport à des déclarations
que je jugerai hâtive voir intempestives
al'annonce de sa démarche en disant qu'
à ce stade il n'y a pas d'investiture
d'un ou d'une candidate dans marche dans
cette circonscription
c'est un geste que j'apprécie mais
néanmoins néanmoins vous êtes élue
socialiste
est ce que vous regrettez le sort qui
est fait depuis quelques jours à manuel
valls ancien premier ministre le sort
que lui réserve à la fois son parti son
ancien parti le parti socialiste mais
également en marche
non je pense que il était très délicat
avant l' annonce des des candidatures
retenues de tordre les règles que la
commission nationale s'était fixé donc
c'est vrai que c'était pas à propos dans
cette phase là maintenant vous avez vu
qu'il ya cent quarante neuf
circonscriptions qui ne sont pas encore
passés vraiment ils ont passé tous les
stades
donc je celle là on fait partie alors
ses 149 circonscription justement
seulement avec beaucoup de déplacés le
sortant absolument est ce que c'est pour
laisser aux députés les républicains le
temps de voir si le premier ministre est
issu de leurs rangs de la droite
pas uniquement des députés ça peut être
aussi des mères des candidats a par
exemple ce matin dans mon département
j'ai appris qu'à mère important de
seine-et-marne président de
l'agglomération de la préfecture rompez
son engagement chez les républicains
pour aller en marche vers macron donc
pour vous
des îles et des élus les républicains
doivent participer au futur gouvernement
dès le moment où ils correspondent aux
critères dont je parle du gouvernement à
haut niveau du gouvernement
oui à partir du moment où ils ont
démontré qu'ils s'engageaient c'est ça
qui est le plus important surtout pour
un ministre il y en a 15 ans pas plus
qu'ils s'engagent vraiment à hanga faire
en sorte que le programme d' emmanuel
macron soit intégralement le leur et
c'est pas la carte n'est que depuis que
vous êtes une ancienne ministre de
françois hollande
est ce que vous seriez déçus s'ils lundi
le premier ministre et est issu des
rangs de la droite
je crois que le mouvement d' emmanuel
macron il est pluraliste
s'il ya des gens
compétent qui est
son candidat à mon poste de ministre et
qui s'engagent effectivement à ce que ce
programme d' emmanuel macron soit
effectif je pense que ce sera une bonne
chose pour la france d' allégations très
rapidement vous avez été investie par le
parti socialiste pour les sénatoriales
de septembre est ce que vous souhaitez
conserver cette étiquette ou est-ce que
vous souhaitez au contraire tu restes
épars en marche mon chéquier un des
premiers soutiens des manuels macron
pour moi il n'y a plus de sujet je sais
que le ps est fini dans sa texture
actuelle moi je suis république en
marché majorité présidentielle et je
souhaiterais qu au sénat il y est
précisément relativement vite un groupe
où chacun dans son pluralisme soient
représentés et on parle d'un report des
élections
ça c'est une idée qui avait déjà été
évoqué il ya quelques mois
bah c'est la seule qui soit un peu
compatible avec le souci d' emmanuel
macron qu'il n'a pas encore exprimé
d'aller vite sur ce sujet notamment par
rapport au nombre de parlementaires
c'est un engagement de campagne il le
tiendra bien merci beaucoup merci
desquels briques d'avoir répondu à nos
questions
merci voilà pour à cette réaction
enregistré un peu plus tôt sur notre
antenne et pianoter parmi les
personnalités investies par en moi je
sais bien le conseiller communication de
françois de gaspard ganzer les anciens
juges d'instruction eric halphen et
laurence vichnievsky
à noter aussi le mathématicien cédric
villani et latour ra marie sara et puis
annoncé comme candidat en marche
le président du rugby club toulonnais
mourad boudjellal a finalement démenti
et à droite on s'inquiète du départ
possible d'élus les républicains vers la
république en marche
bernard accoyer dénonce un véritable
débauchage on les écoute donner une
information ce matin c'est que hier
encore monsieur delevoye et son
entourage
appelez des élus elle est élue dei pour
se livrer leur proposer des débauchages
individuels
donc on voit bien que le renouvellement
est à renouvelle
bon qui en a le nom mais qui méritera
d'être regardé de plus près parce que
finalement avec le recyclage grosso modo
de plus d'un tiers des députés
socialistes avec les personnels
politiques qui entourent le modem de
monsieur qui composent le modem de
monsieur pérou il restera des places
c'est vrai pour les candidats internet
qui ignoreront guère d'expérience et
avec ses députés avec cette majorité
il faudra réformer le pays bon ok tout
ça n'est pas aussi simple qu'on veut
bien nous le dira et on va retrouver à
nouveau sa verrière ogec pour une règle
sont avec la sénatrice et l'air du bas
rhin fabienne keller fabienne keller
bonjour bonjour l'opposition
constructive que vous prenez depuis
quelques jours au sein des républicains
ça ne vous est repartie elle peut aller
jusqu à ce qu elle peut aller jusqu'à
faire partie du futur gouvernement d'
emmanuel macron alors c'est une option
une proposition que nous avons formulées
notamment les jus pis mais aussi les
personnes qui accompagnent bruno le
maire et plusieurs sarkozystes gérald
darmanin vous avez bertrand parce que
nous sentons bien que les français ils
ont le souhait qu'on avant cinq ans
qu'on travaille alors on n'est pas
d'accord sur tout mais on est d'accord
sur des éléments forts du projet alors
pour le gouvernement
je peux pas vous répondre parce que tout
dépend du choix quand même symbolique du
premier ministre et ça j'ai le sentiment
que rien ne filtre et que seuls emmanuel
macron lui même à la réponse c'est à
dire vous réclamez que le premier
ministre soit issu des rôles la droite
je pense que ce serait cohérent avec les
affichages du président il a dit qu'il
voulait gouverner la france au centre
droit centre gauche
il a dit aussi que voilà il voulait
faire de la politique autrement et dans
l'action et je pense que c'est ce qu'il
faut pour la france ces réformes par
exemple du droit du travail qu'on
n'arrive pas à faire depuis plusieurs
gouvernements enfin être en capacité de
créer un consensus un nombre suffisant
de personnes qui adhèrent de
parlementaires d'ailleurs j'ai un
collègue dans le haut rhin il a déjà
pris cette position parce qu'il sent
bien collègues candidats pour la
députation
il sent bien que ses concitoyens
électeurs ben ils ont peu
joint qu'on avance on alors on comprend
votre discours un travailler ensemble
mais en restant ce que vous êtes
mais au sein de votre parti françois
baroin le chef de file un des
législatives à menacer il va falloir
choisir son gros son corps il a même
menacé d'exclusion est ce que vous vous
avez part de certaines représailles
alors moi je respecte la position
officielle des républicains qui est de
s'opposer
il espère une majorité à l'assemblée
nationale qui n'est pas certaine mais
moi il me semble qu'il ya une sorte de
soulagement après cette élection
présidentielle et que les français ont
envie qu'on avance c'est pour ça que moi
je porte ce débat au sein du bureau
politique alors on a évoqué l' exclusion
sur une exclusion c'est toujours un aveu
de faiblesse au vent est ce que vous
pensez de qu'aucun parti n'aura seul la
majorité absolue à l'issue des
législatives et donc il faudra
nécessairement accepté d'entrer dans une
coalition
alors je n'ai pas de boule de cristal
pour les élections mais on peut penser
que il est vraisemblable que l'on marche
n'aura pas une majorité absolue que les
républicains n'auront pas et que
mélenchon qui affirme vouloir la
recherchait pas non plus donc c'est un
élément qui pourrait conduire à cette
coalition mais je crois qu'on peut aussi
avoir la démarche dès maintenant plus
positive de ce discours qui veut prendre
en compte cette nouvelle réalité c'est
pas un des grands partis qui a gagné
cette élection présidentielle la
politique maintenant voilà elle est
vraiment autrement et ça il faut
vraiment laissé au nouveau président
c'est lui qui a qu'a réussi cela mais il
faut aussi rester nous mêmes
moi je sais d'où je viens je suis
strasbourgeois je suis humaniste rhénane
et il faut que nous posions avec nos
sensibilités pour faire avancer la
france
dernière question très rapidement
fabienne keller on parle depuis hier
d'un report possible des élections
sénatoriales
est ce que vous y seriez favorable alors
c'est un élément
un peu technique qui permettrait au
nouveau gouvernement de travailler au
mois de septembre
ça c'est utile mais il semble que le
déséquilibre entre les deux moitiés du
sénat puisse poser problème c'est que la
moitié des départements ne serait pas
représentée par le même nombre de
sénateurs c'est un problème
constitutionnel
mais voilà si cela permet de mieux
travailler dans la foulée de l'élection
d'une nouvelle assemblée
c'est une hypothèse qui est plutôt
positive très bien très bien merci
beaucoup merci fabienne keller d'avoir
répondu à la question merci et merci
beaucoup savaient rien on continue sur
ces législatives avec ce duel annoncé
jean-luc mélenchon patrick mennucci a
marseille il fait des vagues dans le
vieux port le socialiste promet
l'affrontement complet au leader de la
france à 1 soumises qui a été reçu cet
après midi par le sénateur maire jean
claude gaudin
fabien becker c'est un parachutage en
terrain hostile mais en déplacement
aujourd'hui à marseille pour lancer sa
campagne
jean luc mélenchon assume on sommes tous
parachuté dans la nuit s'il y en a qui
l'ont oublié de leur rappel aucun
d'entre eux à l'abri l'adhésion naître
est de même quand je viens ici
eh bien je suis comme partout ailleurs
dans mon pays
sénateur de l'essonne puis battu par
marine le pen à hénin beaumont en 2012
le candidat de la france insoumis
s'attaque cette fois à une
circonscription fortement ancrée à
gauche un point de chute qui surprend
alors que dans la circonscription
voisine de fn est en position de force
le député sortant patrick mennucci
dénonce une démarche de tourisme
politique
c'est un cinquième fois qu'ils changent
de lieu de vote et bien falloir qu'on
discute de tout ça en même temps qu'il
faudra qu'ils nous expliquent que ce
qu'il connaît du centre ville de
marseille à part le vieux-port jours de
soleil à deux meetings
donc voilà il a il a il a choisi la
fronde demeure il va la voir
après avoir annoncé qu'il n'y aura pas
d'accord avec les communistes jean luc
mélenchon poursuit sa stratégie de
cavalier seul à gauche une stratégie
assumée par la france insoumise de 3 170
circonscriptions où notre notre force
politique fait en capacité d'aller au
delà des douze ennemis % des inscrits
qui sont nécessaires pour être présents
deuxième tour donc là notre objectif
c'est la gagne si jean luc mélenchon
avait fini en tête à marseille au
premier tour de la présidentielle
pas sûr toutefois que la cité phocéenne
lui sert de marchepied pour remporter
les législatives
le combat avec patrick mennucci son
ancien compagnon de route au ps
s'annonce âpre nous vous en parlions
hier l'hypothèse d'un report des
élections sénatoriales se précise prévue
le 24 septembre prochain il pourrait
être reportée d'un an
objectif rendre effectives rapidement la
réforme du nombre de parlementaires
elle n'est pas en marche
elle court la rumeur sur un possible
report des élections sénatoriales
prévues en septembre prochain
parti d'un article du bulletin quotidien
elle circule désormais jusqu'au plus
haut sommet de l'état comme le confirme
certains élus beaucoup en parlent
compris des ministres dont je tairai le
nom qui en ont parlé hier je le sais
puisque l'un d'entre eux m'a appelé pour
me parler avant le conseil des ministres
donc c'est un sujet qui semblait selon
les échos que j'ai actée par le
président la république
la moitié de la chambre euro devaient
être concernés soit 170 sénateurs mais
emmanuel macron envisagerait de
repousser leur mandat d'un an pour faire
passer la loi sur la diminution du
nombre de parlementaires n'y a pas
d'autre solution que de reporter les
sénatoriales de 2007 à 2010 8,7 une
bonne solution pauvre oui j'y suis très
favorable j'ai d'ailleurs un peu
travaillé sur le sujet afin de préparer
ce texte de loi pour un d'une diminution
générale de tous les sénateurs en 2021
mais à moins de cinq mois de cette
échéance électorale est-ce possible sans
le souhaitait le président du sénat
laisse la porte ouverte et doit
s'entretenir de ce sujet avec emmanuel
macron
week-end moi je suis par nature pour le
respect des règles en cours
en démocratie ça n'est pas semble-t-il
juridiquement impossible
il reste encore à examiner quelques
aspects constitutionnels la décision
quelle qu'elle soit doit être rapidement
acté car les sénateurs devront pour
valider ce report voter une loi
organique et le conseil constitutionnel
se prononce et dans le reste de
l'actualité au sénat les conclusions de
la commission d' enquête sur les
compensations aux atteintes à la
biodiversité
les sénateurs préconisent la mise en
place d'une stratégie nationale
géraldine beys boulot peut-on compenser
les atteintes faites à la nature lors
d'un grand chantier en protégeant au
moins répandant ce qui est détruit c'est
en tout cas ce que souhaite la loi
biodiversité beauté en 2016 avec le
système de pollueur payeur ça veut dire
que quand on détruit une zone humide
il faut recréer une zone humide donc
c'est beaucoup de générer quand on
détruit une mare pour être un peu
simpliste il faut creuser de nouvelles
mains les sénateurs se sont donc posé la
question en examinant quatre grands
projets
l'autoroute a65 le projet lgv tours
bordeaux
le projet d'aéroport de notre dame des
landes ainsi que la réserve d'actifs
naturels de coups sûrs et le constat est
accablant et la perte liée aux
infrastructures ou à l'étalement urbain
est important qu'on perd du foncier
agricole
on perd à peu près un département tous
les dix ans mais la plupart du temps on
va s'adresser au monde agricole qui gère
la quasi-totalité de l'espace disponible
donc c'est le changement de pratiques
agricoles qui est le principal facteur
en termes de compensations parmi les
préconisations des sénateurs une
meilleure intégration du monde agricole
à la compensation un renforcement de la
collaboration public privé est un axe
important
nous ce qu'on dit fondamentalement on
sait qu'il faut s'adosser sur un
consensus scientifique et si le
consensus scientifique
c'est à dire la compensation n'est pas
possible alors il faut aussi savoir
abandonner des projets les dix sept
sénateurs de sensibilités politiques
différentes ont tout de même réussi à se
mettre d'accord sur des propositions
innovantes
reste à attendre leur mise en
application
françois hollande prépare l'avenir le
futur ex chef de l'état va investir dans
les prochains mois dans sa fondation
lancera la france s'engage alors avant
de parler de son bilan je vous propose
de l'écouter c'était ce matin je me suis
engagé très tôt y compris sur le plan
électoral
la première fois que je me suis présenté
à une élection j'avais 26 ans donc je me
suis déterminé pour que ce ne soit pas
simplement un moment de mon existence
mais véritablement toute mon existence
je n'avais pas pensé nécessairement
lorsque je me suis présenté pour la
première fois au suffrage que je
deviendrais président de la république
certains peuvent avoir même une
accélération et se présenter aux
suffrages pour la première fois et
devenir président de la république ça
peut arriver
je n'avais pas pensé être président de
la république mais je m'étais engagé
pleinement dans la vie publique sans
avoir nécessairement l'idée que je
pourrais me porter à plusieurs mandats
j'en ai exercé un certain nombre mais je
savais que ce premier acte déterminerait
toute ma vie
[Musique]
et mes invités pour évoquer ce bilan du
quinquennat
j'ai le plaisir d'accueillir alain
bergounioux bonsoir vous êtes historien
spécialiste du parti socialiste merci
d'être avec nous j'accueille également
bruno cautrès bon soir chercheur au cnrs
et membre du cevipof est avec nous
également pour nous accompagner il ya
jebrane de directeur conseil chez little
wing c'est une agence conseil en
communication il est coauteur du livre
moi président des couacs aux éditions
kawa merci à tous les trois je vous ai
vu réagir bruno cautrès est ce que
françois hollande vient d'être dit il
nous rappelle un fils n'avait pas
forcément pensé à être président de la
république qu'est ce que ça veut dire
cette phrase justement rétrospectivement
par rapport à tout ce quinquennat très
intéressante parce qu'on retrouve une
rhétorique assez françois hollande c'est
à dire on peut lire à plusieurs niveaux
ce qui est dit on retrouve aussi et bien
une communication qui est à la fois
affectueuse vis-à-vis des manuels macron
et en même temps il ya des éléments qui
sont autant mal ici la vie d'emmanuel
macro il rappelle que lui il a commencé
sa carte politique
à 26 ans donc ça c'est pour dire il n'y
a pas que toi emmanuel qui a été jeune
en politique
et puis aussi moi je n'ai pas tout de
suite pensé être président de la
république j'ai franchi les étapes une à
une
donc on retrouve là quelque chose on
voit que françois hollande est depuis
plusieurs semaines dans un exercice de
retisser à la fois le lien est d'essayer
de construire sa sortie est de
construire une narration d'auto de sa
sortie de la vie politique en tout cas
au minimum de l'elysée est donc là on
voit des éléments qui sont très
intéressants depuis l'élection d'
emmanuel macron et notamment la manière
dont ils essayent de je ne dirais pas de
de prendre emmanuel macron sous son aile
protectrice en tout cas de dire j'y suis
peut-être pas totalement pour rien à
l'élection des manuels me trompe
alain bergounioux cet exercice délicat
de dresser le bilan de ce quinquennat
puisque c'est la première fois qu'un
président finalement sortant ne se
représente pas il a été empêché sa porte
forcément un jugement négatif sur son
action passée le terme d' empêcher a été
utilisé par emmanuel macron pour le pour
le définir
donc donc c'est un je crois que là il
est en train que nous disait bruno
cautrès de construire un récit et dans
un certain sens
manuel mâcon ayant été proche de lui
il montre aux français et les images de
la journée de 8 mai était
caractéristique de ce point de vue que
dans le fond son bilan n'est pas si
mauvais puisque anne ses conseillers
hans ministre devient président de la
république donc c'est une manière de de
jeu le valoriser le bilan mais en
finesse aussi pour montrer les
différences parce que ensuite il ya les
mois qui vont venir
on verra quelle quel discours il tient
et qu'elle est sûre quel point il veut
insister mais là c'est la construction
effectivement d'un récit qui jusqu'à
présent c'est ça le paradoxe manqué au
quinquennat pour vous le fait qu'il ne
se représente pas par définition ça veut
dire que son bilan est forcément négatif
alors son plan politique que ça c'est
aux observateurs politiques de juger
mais en tout cas ce plan de la
communication et d'un symbole c'est vrai
que la campagne électorale n'a pas
permis de faire le bilan de justement du
mandat de françois hollande ps qui ne
s'est pas représenté on a vu que ce
bilan était complètement absent des
discours à la fois personne ne voulait
pas effectivement des bas ou marine le
pen et c'est justement le faire porter
malade micro et macro justement le
rejeter pour ne pas le porter donc c'est
vrai que le bilan n'a pas été fait
françois hollande et se retrouve
justement l'obligé aujourd'hui une fois
qu'il sort de l'e10 est obligé de faire
alors qu'il n'a fait ni pendant son
quinquennat
ni justement pendant cette campagne
puisqu'il n'était pas partie prenante à
bord n'ont que 13 c'est vrai qu'il avait
la lourde tâche de faire fructifier cet
héritage socialiste après françois
mitterrand au final est est-ce qu'il y
est parvenu
difficile à dire aujourd'hui parce qu'on
manque encore de recul qui est certain
c'est que le mandat de françois hollande
a été caractérisée par une forme
d'impasse au bout d'un moment c'est à
dire que françois hollande s'est
retrouvé président de la république à
l'issue d'une primaire certes mais aussi
à l'issue des primaires ou un autre
candidat qui était
dans l'est aussi en attente n'a pas pu
être candidat à la présidence de
république et françois hollande a
inscrit un mandat qui était amanda qui
en même temps s'inscrivait dans les pas
de françois hollande et en même temps on
était plus dans la même histoire que
françois hollande
les communistes ne sont pas au
gouvernement les écologistes de 2012 ne
sont pas exactement l'équivalent de ce
qu'on avait connu au moment de l'union
de la gauche et de et de françois
mitterrand et surtout françois hollande
va subir de plein fouet non seulement
bien sûr les crises qu'on va avoir au
plan ou plan économique mais surtout une
division extrêmes de la vie sociale et
sur la question de l'europe et à
l'époque de à l'époque de fougue des
mines d'or voilà on dont il a été le
premier secrétaire du parti ou en du
référendum pour qu'on voit qu'il ya là
quelque chose de très important qui va
marquer avec des conséquences
extrêmement profonde tout le mandat de
françois hollande et qui a des
répercussions jusqu'à ce qu'on a vu
aujourd'hui quasiment y compris dans les
fractures à l'intérieur de la campagne
du candidat à mon avocat et moi que vous
faut vous faisiez la comparaison avec
françois mitterrand je crois qu'il faut
dire très honnêtement qu'il a hérité en
2012 une situation beaucoup plus
difficile que celle de françois
mitterrand 1981 ou celle de lionel
jospin en 1997 ce qu'il y avait vraiment
une conjonction après la grande crise
financière et économique de 2008 de
difficultés et puis difficultés
économiques c'est évident au point de
vue des déficits de la dette de la perte
de compétitivité de la france mais aussi
de difficultés politiques parce qu'il
faut rappeler que au premier tour de
l'élection présidentielle de 2012 la
gauche rassemblée et qui était en plus
divisée ne faisait que 43 et quelques
pour cent des suffrages donc il était à
la fois économiquement et politiquement
dans une situation difficile et c'est là
qu'il faudrait rentrer commencé à entrer
dans le fond du débat et c'est ça je
pense l'un des fils sinon rouge tout au
moins un des fils de du quinquennat
c'est qu'il a essayé de de sérier les
difficultés il n'a pas voulu et c'est
pour ça que la comparaison avec emmanuel
macron est intéressante parce que
emmanuel macron était un de ses
conseillers en 2012 et dans l'équipe
les deux qu'on trouve notamment des
économistes des manuels macron on a les
mêmes
jean pisani ferry et d'autre et c est là
françois hollande d'emblée a eu un choix
un certain nombre de ses conseillers
dont emmanuel macron lui conseillé de
faire une série de réformes
structurelles importantes tout de suite
pour réveiller un potentiel de
croissance et lui ne les a pas écoutés
il a voulu diluer les choses avancent et
par étapes d'une première étape après
une 2e et puis la troisième
redistriburez donc il a il a réagi en
politique et non pas on est au pain
économiste et il est assez intéressant
de voir qu'aujourd'hui
emmanuel macron a tiré la leçon de ses
débuts du quinquennat et on verra
évidemment ce qui se passe parce que les
choses ont toujours que compliqué mais
lui il veut faire des réformes forte
tout de suite donc et françois hollande
a réagi en politique et il a pensé que
calendrier plus permettrait de résoudre
les problèmes les uns après les autres
sans coaliser les difficultés au rize et
on reverra peut-être on aura l'occasion
g7 inspire de 2013 2014 il s'est trouvé
dans une impasse politique et s'est vue
les choix des début de quinquennat ou de
cette tenait autrefois sont évidemment
tout à fait majeur justement vous ne
faites la transition à la bourgogne ou
pas ce qu'on va voir ce sujet de cendras
à requerra puisque françois hollande on
l'a dit il se veut le chantre du
compromis et de la synthèse au final
n'aura pas réussi à asseoir son autorité
il laisse un ps en déshérence alors à
l'origine du délitement ses choix
souvent incompris qui ont conduit à la
démission de dont de nombreux ministres
c'est un sujet de cendres faire qu'à 6
mai 2012 la gauche en liesse pour fêter
la victoire de françois hollande
merci peuple de france il s'y rassembler
d'avoir permis que la gauche ait un
successeur à françois mitterrand
cinq ans plus tard dans l'incapacité à
se représenter
françois hollande laisse un bilan
politique au goût amer
dès les premiers mois de son quinquennat
quoique et recadrages s'enchaînent
jusqu'à ce qu'arnaud montebourg soit
débarqué du gouvernement en 2014
après avoir dénoncé des hausses d'impôts
non prévu dans le programme du candidat
hollande
le monde entier nous presse nous
supplient même de faire cesser ces
politiques d'austérité absurde
même sort pour benoît hamon aurélie
filippetti les cautions de gauche ne
participeront pas au deuxième
gouvernement avec manuel valls ni les
verts la majorité s'effrite puis s'ouvre
une crise morale avec la déchéance de
nationalité voulu par françois hollande
en 2015 après les attentats christiane
taubira figure emblématique de la gauche
quitte le gouvernement sur un désaccord
politique majeure je choisis d'être
fidèle à moi même
fidèle à nous les tensions s'accentuent
avec les loups gauche des parlementaires
opposés à la politique sociale libérale
mise en place françois hollande peine à
obtenir une majorité sur de nombreux
projets de loi je connais les
immobilismes et les conservatismes et je
sais aussi que certains préfèrent les
postures à la réforme mais les passages
en force avec le 49-3 sur les lois
macron et l comrie durcissent encore le
camp des socialistes frondeur et
entérine la fracture au sein du ps nous
pensons qu'il n'est pas possible
d'imposer au groupe socialiste une
unanimité de façade en raison de
l'impasse économique et politique dans
lequel on se trouve
la gauche à son apogée en 2012 enchaîne
les défaites électorales
la synthèse cher à françois hollande
s'achève sur le score pathétique du ps à
la présidentielle
un parti en voie de disparition on
continue le bilan du quinquennat de
françois hollande avec un nouvel ami tu
es qui nous a rejoint sur ce plateau
pascal boniface bonsoir directeur de
l'iris et l'institut de relations
internationales et stratégiques
auteur de ce livre je t'aimais bien tu
sais aux éditions max milo dans lequel
vous analyse
le déclassement de la france aux yeux du
monde peut-être une question pour vous
dia jebrane on a vu ces différentes
étapes qui ont marqué le bilan politique
du quinquennat de françois hollande
est ce que il n'ya pas lui aussi
peut-être trop d'ambiguïtés dès 2012 qui
ont conduit à l'exaspération des
français aux difficultés qui n'a pu le
rencontrer françois hollande
effectivement en force hollande n'a
jamais en fait donné la ligne directrice
de son quinquennat le fil rouge qui
voulait donner et inversement quand il
avait des accès d'autorité
il a voulu justement il est piégé en
donnant une grille d'analysé qui l'a
complètement encore maryse et vis-à-vis
des journalistes et des observateurs
notamment l'inversion de la courbe du
chômage que justement il a conditionné
sa candidature et le succès de son
quinquennat cet indicateur est il a
forcé en fait les gens à le juger par
rapport à ça donc justement en n'étant
pas claires sur ce qu'ils voulaient
faire la une en mai le pays notamment
par rapport à ses promesses parce que je
pense que le grand la grande difficulté
de françois hollande c'était le grand
écart qu'il a dû faire entre ses
promesses de campagne campagne très à
gauche et une fois qu'il a été au
gouvernement des mesures qui étaient
plutôt libérale en tout cas favorisant
la compétitivité donc on sait de ce
grand écart il n'a pas su gérer
et justement ce qui a créé un désamour
dans dans l'opinion et s'il ya juste un
mot qu'on peut retenir est que revient
dans la bouche de françois hollande et
que vous reprenez vous c'est la
réconciliation
françois hollande a été lui aussi sur la
réconciliation par rapport à un
quinquennat nous la sarkozie qui était
pas apaisé et on voit que il n'a pas
réussi à vaincre on mise aussi là dessus
pour dire je serai le candidat le
président de la réconciliation
brno 4 à saluer lui a valu de nombreux
procès en trahison tout au long de 2,5
et nassez changement de cap à oui mais
qui sont sans doute lié à un problème de
à la fois de fil rouge de narration est
sans aucun doute de quelques moments clé
sur lequel il a manqué de donner leurs
significations assez beau manquer parce
que quand on reprend le discours du
bourget moi je les réécoute être l
entreprise vraiment quand on leur et
écoutent le discours du bourget on
s'aperçoit qu'on ne peut pas dire
françois hollande et trahi ses
engagements de campagne de très nombreux
points du discours du bourget qui soit
ont été clairement mis en oeuvre soit
ont été mis à moitié en oeuvre soit il a
essayé de les mettre en oeuvre il a été
bloqué par tout un tas de mécanismes et
au fond ce qu'on a surtout retenu du
discours du bouger c'est mon ennemi
c'est le monde de la finance et je
revêts renégocier le traité de stabilité
budgétaire
il ya eu un moment où françois hollande
ait said interpréter ces
ce double objectif c'était la crise
grecque c'est vraiment de la crise
grecque on a à la fois mon ennemi c'est
la finance vous voyez par rapport aux
allemands par rapport à chaud bleus et
puis je vais renégocier le traité
stabilité budgétaire
je donne une impulsion à l'europe on
conserve les grecs dans la zone euro
donc là le l'europe c'est quelque chose
qui n'est pas seulement une question
économique c'est pas seulement une
question de stabilité budgétaire
donc c'est surtout une question de
narration et notamment au moment au
début de l'année 2014
lorsqu'il fait sa fameuse conférence de
presse où il dit oui ce social démocrate
bien sûr et c'est à ce moment là où
françois hollande probablement manque la
balle de match de son quinquennat qui
est de s'engouffrer de dire bah oui
effectivement c'est bien ça et je vais
déployer tout un projet je veux mettre
en oeuvre toute une histoire et après le
2 le sentiment de constamment navigué
effectivement entre entre différents
courants gauche droite à l'intérêt de sa
famille politique
allez je crois que ça c'est le point
important parce que c'est le point de la
méthode politique et comme nous avons
peu de temps je prendrai qu'un seul
exemple pour montrer qui enfant il n'a
pas pu expliquer exactement ce qu'il
faisait parce que la question européenne
il avait été engagé à renégocier le
traité le tsc g il s'est rendu compte et
il l'a dit dans le fameux livre avec les
deux journalistes du monde qu'il n'y
avait pas de rapport de force pour
négocier avec l'allemagne que même dans
l'europe du sud espagne italie nous
voulait le suivre c'est un bras de fer
avec l'allemagne
donc alors ce qu'il a fait c'est à dire
qu'il a signé le traité
il a pris des engagements et il a obtenu
une tolérance de la commission
européenne est de l'allemagne pour que
la france diminue ses déficits lentement
et ont d'ailleurs ne toujours pas arrivé
aux 3% alors que c'était bon et aimer ça
ils ne pouvaient pas l'expliquer parce
qu'il aurait fallu expliquer justement
le ce deal habile mais qui n'étaient pas
claires et du fait il n'a pas mené une
réelle politique d'austérité
même s'il ya eu délit
mythe dans les dépenses etc le pouvoir
d'achat a continué à augmenter dans
cette période certes pas pour tout le
monde c'était le problème du chômage et
lancinant et alors il a été accusé haute
trahison par toute la gauche et même au
sein du parti socialiste de mener une
politique d'austérité d'en faire arrêter
cette politique d'austérité était
extrêmement modéré mais ça ils ne
pouvaient pas l'expliquer parce que ça
tenait un deal avec essentiellement la
chancelière
et puis que je suivais la commission
européenne
donc il a on a mené une politique très
modérée au point de vue aux restrictions
en réalité des dépenses publiques très
loin de ce que pouvait raconter la
gauche
la protection sociale a continué à
progresser mais y comment expliquer cela
or c'est tout le problème du de françois
hollande c'est une méthode politique
fait d'habileté pour diluer les
difficultés pour les seriez mais au
total
évidemment et comme il a eus il a eu
vous avez tout le monde avait remarqué
ce texte
cette fameuse expression toujours dans
ce livre qui est quand même très
intéressant pour comprendre le
quinquennat j'ai pas eu de bol donc tout
le monde à dieu qu'est ce que ça veut
dire avoir pas de bol en fait ils
pensaient dilué difficulté et il croyait
que la croissance il ya une dynamique
cyclique de la croissance et qu'elle
reviendrait simplement elle n'est pas
revenue et donc après il ya eu une
impasse et la fiscalité est apparue
beaucoup trop beaucoup trop forte et on
s'est retrouvé dès 2013 2014
dans une inde dans une très grande
difficulté politique qui n'avaient pas
anticipé comme cela je crois que c'est
comme ça qu'on peut commencer à rendre
compte et de ce qui s'est passé dans ce
quinquennat
pascal boniface sûrs de vous entendre ce
qu'on a entendu dans le sujet de sandra
serre car la question de la déchéance de
nationalité en salle provoqué une
véritable crise morale à gauche sa
conduite a été rappelé à la démission de
christiane taubira sur la lutte contre
le terrorisme là aussi il n'a pas su
expliquer ses choix
alain bergounioux évoquait justement ce
problème d'incompréhension de demandes
de pédagogie n'ont peut-être pas mise à
part sur ce problème très sensible
de déchéance de nationalité qui avait
finalement conduit à une rupture
extrêmement important puisque c'est sur
ce point qui a mené le maquereau s'est
séparé de manuel valls est donc de
françois hollande et à l'extérieur aussi
alors qu'il avait réussi une très belle
réconciliation avec l'algérie et qu'il
avait de très bonnes relations avec les
pays du maghreb
ça a été vue aussi comme quelque chose
de stigmatisant mais pour le reste par
rapport à l'oeuvre contre le terrorisme
jamais il n'est tombé dans les
provocations dans les raccourcis il a
évité les termes dix thèmes au fascisme
et était beaucoup plus calme que son
premier ministre
là dessus il a refusé tout amalgame sur
musulmans terrorisme etc tout en
maintenant le cap et c'est vrai que sur
ce domaine là alors on pourrait dire il
y en a beaucoup parlé
peut-être qu'on a trop parlé ça ça notre
sujet il le pouvait penser qu'il n'était
pas possible de faire autrement par
rapport au public mais en tous les cas
il n'a pas mis d'huile sur le feu sur
les peurs des français
à ce moment là et c'était extrêmement
important parce que dans d'autres pays
ou d'autres étrangers politiques avaient
une vision un peu plus je dirais
enflammé de la façon de lutter contre le
terrorisme ou même simplement
d'explication des causes du terrorisme
n'est pas lui qui a dit que comprendre
c'est légitimer et c'est donc il ya
quand même maintenu le cap en donnant
les moyens de lutte alors on peut dire
vigipirate et c'est un peu le point par
point à ergoter dans tous les cas il
s'est engagé et à des moments clés a
aussi bien pour le ser le 11 janvier
2015 que après le 13 novembre
il a joué son rôle de chef de l'état en
donnant les moyens de la protection du
territoire des citoyens mais sans tomber
dans les excès de peur et c'est pour
cela que cet épisode des chances
vassalité est d'autant plus incongrue
est d'autant plus bizarre parce que là
du coup il a voulu faire une sorte de
coup médiatique dont on sait que enfin
débattre mais il est certain que ce qui
commet des attentats ne sont pas
effrayés par une éventuelle perte de
nationalité est donc là on a vu qu'il a
plus voulu répondre à une demande
du milieu politique et médiatique à une
réel besoin de lutte contre le
terrorisme
le 13 avril dernier lisait à
l'hebdomadaire le point je suis
malheureux qu'une partie de la gauche
n'ont pas compris tout ce que nous
faisions
c'est là aussi la clé peut-être pour
comprendre qu'on n'a jamais su ce
qu'était le hollandisme et le dit
lui-même en fait il dit c'est pas moi de
définir ce que c'est le rôle en dise pas
ce que sera la présidence françois
hollande est en fait le problème de
françois hollande c'est que la laisser
les autres parler pour lui ne l'a jamais
voulu justement lui porter un discours
et une vision un fil rouge lova la fin
oui mais ça c'est hideux c'est typique
de sa personne et parce que si je fais
le constat sur les questions de
relations internationales
il n'a jamais été en course actuelle il
n'a pas fait comme mitterrand macron
s'est référé dans la campagne au goulot
mitterrandisme hollande a fui ce terme
comme la fuite ou d'autres termes est
donc comme c'est essentiellement un
pragmatique il a toujours eu peur au
niveau géopolitique mais je pense que
c'est pareil dans les domaines dont vous
êtes vous ou socialistes d'être enfermé
dans un chalet a theory qui l'aurait
rendu prisonnier et sa méthode c'est
toujours de faire effectivement avec
habileté et des arrangements mais s'il
ya une doctrine il est prisonnier et
donc mais en même temps de temps en
temps il faut parler aux gens il faut
expliquer ce que l'on fait dans un cadre
doctrinal et là c'est ça qui a manqué
fait que les journalistes ont parlé à
dire un lieu unique les commentateurs et
du coup qui ont installé un bruit
négatif autour de sa présidence il n'a
pas réussi à le contrer on compte rires
alors on continue d'analyser le bilan du
quinquennat de françois hollande et on
sait qu'il avait conditionné sa
candidature à une inversion de la courbe
du chômage le pari était osé et la
poursuit tout au long du quinquennat
retour sur le bilan économique de
françois hollande avec mounir ceci dès
le début du quinquennat françois
hollande se lance dans la bataille pour
l'emploi avec une idée fixe l'objectif
que je me suis fixé c'est d'inverser la
courbe du chômage d'ici la fin de
l'année
plusieurs mesures vont être mises en
place pour stimuler les embauches
les contrats de génération et les
emplois d'avenir pour lutter contre le
chômage des jeunes
325 moins de 25 ans ont bénéficié de ces
contrats de cinq ans maximum
mais le coeur de la stratégie a reposé
sur un défi lancé au patronat je propose
un pacte de responsabilité aux
entreprises il est fondé sur un principe
simple moins de charges sur le travail
moins de contraintes sur leurs activités
et en même temps
une contrepartie plus d'embûches et plus
de dialogue social
le pacte de responsabilité couplé au
crédit impôt compétitivité emploi a
dégagé 33 milliards d'euros pour les
entreprises
une somme qui leur a permis de restaurer
leurs marges en berne depuis la crise de
2008 mais n'a pas entraîné la création
d'un million d'emplois comme le
promettait le patron du medef
en cinq ans la courbe s'est stabilisé
mais pas inverser le président avait
fait ses calculs en pariant sur une
croissance retrouvée dynamique dans les
faits elle a navigué entre 0,2 et 1,1
pour cent sur le quinquennat
insuffisant pour doper l'activité la
consommation n'a pas pu jouer son rôle
de moteur traditionnel car les ménages
ont vu leur impôt grimpé de près de 16
milliards en cinq ans sur le plan
budgétaire françois hollande avait
promis de ramener le déficit sous les 3%
dès 2013
finalement ce chiffre sera atteint fin
2017 avec une baisse de plus de 20
milliards
en revanche la dette a continué à se
creuser malgré la faiblesse des taux
d'intérêt elle s'élevait fin 2016 à 98
4% du pib
bruno cautrès cette inversion de la
courbe du chômage seul a poursuivi tout
au long de son quinquennat françois
hollande avec ce pacte de compétitivité
qui n'a pas forcément produit les effets
escomptés
on revient à ce qu'on disait tout à
l'heure avec cette conversion au social
libéralisme
en tout cas il a été un peu accusé
justement de naviguer entre deux voies
quel regard vous portez un regard à
plusieurs plusieurs dimensions plus d'un
niveau de danse un premier premier temps
on peut dire que françois hollande ce
piège l'unm avec l'inversion de la
courbe d'autant plus qu'il a un deuxième
objectif au début de son mandat qui est
celui de la jeunesse et j'ai toujours
été je me suis toujours interrogé sur
les raisons pour lesquelles il a plus
mis l'accent à un moment donné sur
l'inversion de la coupe plutôt que sur
la question de la sur la question de la
jeunesse et sur la question de la
jeunesse dans un premier temps du
quinquennat on dit on va recruter des
enseignants
mais est ce vraiment répondre aux
demandes et aux besoins de la jeunesse
que répond que de recruter des
enseignants et sur l'inversion de la
courbe il ya une deuxième lecture au
fond on voit aujourd'hui emmanuel macron
dit eh bien moi je vais fixer des
objectifs et les critères d'évaluation
aux ministres et ceux qui ne tiendront
pas leurs objectifs seront sanctionnés
les députés dépose candidats
candidate dans marche dépose une lettre
de motivation et quelque part on voit
que françois hollande en même temps est
un détour à où tout premiers dirigeants
du monde démocratique qui s'est lui même
fixé un critère d'évaluation à qui en a
tiré les conséquences et donc d'une
certaine manière si on reprenait sur une
très longue sur une très longue durée ce
avec un peu de distance
on va voir françois hollande a aussi en
maintenant montrer aux autres dirigeants
aux autres potentiels dirigeants du pays
car moment donné si on considère qu'on
est un échec sur un de ces dossiers
majeurs on en tire les conséquences et
ça c'est très intéressant puisque l'un
des regard que portent les français sur
leur politique c'est que c'est une
classe d'individus qui ne qui n'est pas
sanctionné pour ce qu'ils sont en échec
106 sans doute faut que les français
pensent à néant tous qu'elles le pensent
beaucoup donc j'ai un regard un peu
partagés sur cette question de
l'inversion de la courbe à la barre oui
d'abord notons le pas le fait que c'est
en toute fin de quinquennat derniers
mois quasiment pendant la campagne et
florales qu'un certain nombre
d'indicateurs passe au vert est tout
simplement comme je le disais tout à
l'heure
françois hollande a pensé que la
dynamique de croissance jour est plutôt
c'était quand même fondé la tuer pour
ceux qui ont de la mémoire qui quand
françois hollande était professeur à
sciences po maître de conférences à
sciences po avec pierre moscovici un
cours d'économie dans les années 80 et
ils étaient les partisans de la
croissance endogène donc hollande a
pensé qu'il y avait un cycliste et la
théorie des cycles et qui avait ainsi
donc là évidemment c'est rose retrouvé
en difficulté ensuite il faut être là
vous en veut employer le mot je crois
qu'il faut parler là dessus et avoir un
débat là-dessus parce que social libéral
oui et non parce que ça
ça ne va peut-être pas le meilleur
interprète de mon avis du quinquennat
donc parce que la politique de l'offre
qui lui a été reprochée par la gauche de
la gauche par une partie par ce triste
c'est qu'on fait françois mitterrand et
lionel jospin s'est déjà été pratiqué
évidemment et à partir de 83
laurent fabius avait donné comme
consigne aux entreprises publiques de
faire du profit
donc il c'était une politique de l'offre
qui a été menée et lionel jospin avec
tommy justement parce qu'il n'y avait
pas il y avait un manque il a toujours
manqué ce récit explicatif donc il il a
mené certes une politique de l'offre et
avec des éléments de politique libérale
comme depuis 1983 il n'y a pas de grande
nouveauté mais en même temps comme je
les dis la protection sociale n'a pas
été mise en cause elle a même progressé
il ya eu des mesures qui ont été prises
qui l'ont fait progresser par rapport à
ce qu'elle était et puis il a tenté très
sincèrement le dialogue social
parce que là on vit tous sur l'image de
l'année 2016 et manifestations la loi
travail qu'il aurait dû n'être plus
vigilants sur cette loi travail manque
d'un boris expliquera plus tard
mais au départ 2012 2013 2014 il ya les
grandes conférences social il ya les
accords interprofessionnels et donc en
fait comme le disait très bien pascal
boniface françois hollande c'est un
pragmatique et donc il a additionné des
éléments de politique de nature assez
différentes les uns sociaux-démocrates
les autres sociaux libéraux et avec une
volonté effectivement de dialogue social
et d'apaisement
simplement il les résultats n'ont pas
été là parce que et c'est là qu'on
pourrait avoir un débat plus
contradictoire parce que certains disent
parce qu'il a eu tort il fallait
pratiquer une politique de la demande
les frondeurs etc et puis d'autres
disent c'était un peu la thèse d'
emmanuel macron et c'est sa thèse c'est
parce qu'il n'est pas allé assez loin
dans les réformes structurelles et qu'il
est resté à mi-chemin au lieu d'aller
vraiment au fond et c'est vrai que
paradoxalement faire une loi travail
telle qu'elle a été en fin de
quinquennat
c'était quand même pas dire là d'une
habileté extraordinaires parce que c'est
des choses qu'il fallait faire bien
avant quand le gouvernement il y avait
une certaine encore popularité pour
qu'elle a baissé assez vite mais voilà
donc et je crois que le pragmatisme a
ses mérites mais il a aussi ses
faiblesses ses jibrane est-ce qu'ils
n'auraient pas dû peut-être on parlait
des ambiguïtés des dès le début du
quinquennat
élargir aussi à son gouvernement dès
2012 peut-être au centre en faisant
rentrer des personnels comme françois
bayrou pour mieux faire accepter cette
politique de l'offre qu'il a mises en
place par la suite si complètement après
ce qui est paradoxal dans françois
hollande ont beau connaisseur de la vie
politique c'est qu'il a placé son
quinquennat sous le signe du chômage de
la campagne puis après dès les premiers
jours sans mandat
donc c'est vrai qu'il aurait pu faire un
acte politique fort pour expliquer cette
démarche là mais moi je me pose la
question pourquoi il a voulu être sur ce
terrain glissant de l'économie on se
rappelle de milieux de villepin qui ont
été promises qui avait placé aussi son
quinquennat soit bataille contre le
chômage
donc ces internes qui sont pour beaucoup
de politiques depuis un moment pareil
c'est pas forcément le terrain où la
gauche la plus légitime vodka plus
crédible il aurait pu effectivement que
c'est son quinquennat sur la protection
sociale sur le mariage pour tous des
vraies réformes sociétales qui l'a mené
donc le chef françois hollande est assez
assez une pose question en tout cas et
on le voit bien dans les mots qu'ils
utilisent
il passe d'abord de boîte à outils qui
est un mot justement qui ne veut pas
dire grand-chose qui ramène la
présidence quelque chose d'assez
opérationnel il passe ensuite impact on
parle ensuite de justement que
l'inversion de la courbe du chômage on
sait il n'a jamais vraiment trouvé le
bon ton en tout cas le bon vocabulaire
pour expliquer ce à quoi sa politique
aux français il ya un écart aussi entre
les réformes sur le plan sociétal qui
auront ils réussi qui était populaire et
l'absence du tas économique donc
beaucoup de gens se sont dit on s'occupe
toujours une et maryse y un des
privilégiés d'une certaine catégorie
sociaux social celui professionnel et
donc ce décalage entre des réformes qui
ont été dix ont largement approuvé au
moins dans
dans certains milieux mais qui donc
n'ont pas profité beaucoup de gens et
l'absence de résultats concrets
notamment sur le chômage c'était évident
et pour revenir scudier c'est sûr que le
discours du bourget pourrait peut-être
être plus global mais ce qu'ont retenu
les jaunes et ce qui justifiait le vote
j-1 du coup en 2012 il bat largement
mélenchon parce que il incarne le vote
de gauche et il s - espace à mélenchon
et cécile mélenchon a eu plus d'espacés
en 2017
ceci peut être en mémoire de 2012 et 2
nd est vécu comme des engagements non
respectés par rapport aux questions
sociales
on a un peu abandonné disons que
hollande a privilégié le sociétal sur le
social et même vaste l'identitaire sur
le social mais le social a quand même
été même s'il n'a pas été bafouée par
rapport aux promesses par amour aux
espoirs de 2012 il a quand même été un
peu l'oublié du quinquennat il n'y a pas
eu de la grande réforme symbolique
il ya eu enfin les grandes réformes qui
étaient plus le dessin bonne humeur sous
mitterrand parce qu'il ya eu une
politique de l'offre mais des réformes
importantes et sous lionel jospin
les 35 heures et dominique strauss kahn
à l'économie avec une politique très en
réalité très social libéral et des
privatisations
mais là il a manqué d il ya eu des
petites réformes sociales mais par rien
qui n'a acquis n'a marqué l'opinion
qu'ils soient suffisamment les initiants
lisible pour équilibrer le par exemple
mariage pour tous qui est la grande
réforme sociétale mais qui effectivement
ne le pensait intéressé qu'une partie de
la france et pas l'autre
je pense moi n'en ferais si je pense que
tous les problèmes dont dont on parle si
on on essaie de mettre côté la
responsabilité politique de deux de
françois hollande c'est tout simplement
que une autre personnalité aurait
affronté sans aucun doute les mêmes
difficultés et manière là qu'on va les
affronter la politique dans les pays de
l'europe
globalement c'est une politique en deux
dimensions il ya la dimension socio
économique qui continue d'animer une
très grande partie du débat public des
clivages sur lequel vient se greffer la
question de la gauche et la droite
et puis la deuxième dimension plus du
changement culturel du changement social
et
tout toute forme le taux de formation
politique doit essayer de naviguer un
peu entre les exigences contradictoires
de ses dimensions si on va trop sur
l'économique
eh bien on va peut-être s'aliéner une
partie de l'opinion qui elle aspire à du
changement culturel et sociétal et
réciproquement et rappelons nous qu'au
début de son mandat
françois hollande beaucoup de gens à
gauche et notamment à l'inter du parti
socialiste disait avec les réformes de
société qu'il a initiés il oublie
l'objectif numéro 1 la lutte contre le
chômage les classes populaires et le
parti socialiste depuis maintenant 20
ans est dans une sorte de quête des
classes populaires qu'il a perdu en
partie ou même en assez large partie on
l'a vu encore dans les élections de 2017
et la gauche n'arrive pas à faire son
deuil et des classes populaires parce
que sinon évidemment
qu'est ce que c'est que la gauche si
elle abandonne message d'espoir pour les
classes populaires et donc cette
question elle expose et pas seulement au
parti socialiste elle se faisant tous
les partis sociaux-démocrates et
françois hollande il a essayé de jongler
à travers tout ça mau pour sa
rattraperait emmanuel macron pour vous
soulignez ce que vous dites parce que il
faut essayer d'être équilibrés c'est à
dire que en fait quand on regarde
l'europe
tous les gouvernements de type
travailliste sociaux démocrates
socialistes ont connu des difficultés
qu'ils soient en angleterre la fin de la
troisième voie en espagne c'est évident
unis currency qui est un peu le
maquereau italiens aussi donc
donc c'est pour ça qu'il faut quand même
il ya on va y aller les critiques sont
utile et nécessaire et puis comme ça se
termine mal pour évidemment on voit bien
qu'il ya beaucoup de choses qui n'ont
pas marché on a commencé en expliqué
quelques-unes mais la situation était
extrêmement difficile et aucun les
grands leaders socialistes européens n'a
réussit dans son pays tout juste est
encore sur un équilibre fragile le
gouvernement des sociaux démocrates
suédois mais c'est même en suède même en
suède c'est difficile donc donc il faut
voir
on est dans un ensemble etc les
difficultés d'un de la social démocratie
européenne à faire face aux
contradictions et des injections
contradictoire parce qu'il faut faire
plusieurs choses
ils ne vont pas ensemble donc on verra
sur cette question qu'on parle de celui
qui voulait quand même incarner un
président normal proche du peuple et qui
atteint des sommets d'impopularité
réputé pudique avare en confidences il
s'est finalement épongées auprès des
journalistes cécile 6 au premier pas à
l'elysée et première maladresse françois
hollande serre la main de nicolas
sarkozy mais ne le raccompagne pas
jusqu'à sa voiture
inexpérience ou impolitesse dès le
départ le nouveau chef de l'état ne
maîtrise pas les codes et donne l'image
d'un président qui a du mal à enfiler
les habits de la fonction même jour son
costume prend déjà l'eau il remonte les
champs elysées sous une pluie battante
une mauvaise météo qui ne quittera pas
avec une image emblématique sur l'île de
saint lô françois hollande refuse le
parapluie et prononce un discours sous
un véritable déluge un président trempé
désacraliser anormal mauvaise
communication aussi lors de la sphère
leonarda une collégienne rome de 15 ans
dont l'arrestation et l'expulsion avait
suscité l'émoi des français françois
hollande veut lui même éteindre
l'incendié
il propose dans une allocution téléphone
fille de rentrer en france mais sans sa
famille non lui répond l'adolescent par
médias interposés séquence
catastrophique pour le chef de l'état
ridiculisés mais ce qui écorne
particulièrement son image ce sont les
feuilletons liées à sa vie privée
le tweet d'abord de valérie trierweiler
qui encourage la ddt
resserre de ségolène royal aux
législatives la photo ensuite dans un
magazine people où la france est la
compagne de françois hollande découvre
la liaison du président avec julie gayet
le livre enfin merci pour ce moment de
son ex compagne valérie trierweiler qui
étalent au grand jour leur rupture et
dévoile le surnom que donne le président
aux gens modestes des fameux sans dents
il y a quelques mois la publication d'un
livre confidences
un président ne devrais pas dire ça dont
les révélations consterne dans son
propre camp dégrade encore un peu plus
sa stature de chef d'état et donne
l'impression que françois hollande passe
plus de temps avec les journalistes qu'à
s'occuper des affaires de l'état sem
gébrane vous qui êtes expert en
communication politique à un mot quand
même sur ces cinq années et sur la
gestion de son image elle a été
calamiteuse je pense qu'elle était
calamiteuse des as est effectivement un
des facteurs de sa non représente enfin
non candidature à l'élection
présidentielle
il a jamais en fait su trouver ni le bon
ton ni la bonne hauteur justement multi
du livre justement est assez révélateur
à présent tu ne devrais pas dire ça
parce que françois n'a jamais su ce
qu'un président devaient dire ou devait
faire il a jamais vraiment compris en
deux c'est en tout cas le costume du
président et on voit bien même sur des
choses très symbolique sur le fait que
souligner de cinq ans il prononce son
discours oui dit c'est bien montrer
comme les résistants en leur temps que
j'affronte les éléments il comprend pas
en fait de l'effet désastreux que ça sur
l'opinion il sur son image enfin qu'il
arrive pas justement à percevoir la
perception que les français ont enfin là
l'image les effets de sur son image que
les français à avoir de lui et c'est
assez désastreux et puis il a pas non
plus compris le changement avec les
médias d'information en continu avec les
réseaux sociaux on le voit il veut laver
trailer avec la sphère le jardin il n'a
pas compris en fait par rapport à
l'époque où il était premier secrétaire
du parti souhaité communiquer
directement avec journalistes par sms il
a pas compris le monde avait
radicalement changé et que justement la
communication avait complètement changé
d'époque et de mode de fonctionnement
mais il faut peut-être une petite nuance
quand même parce que c'est vrai mais en
même temps c'est le même homme qui a
pris des décisions en courant importante
en politique internationale et tout le
monde reconnaît qu'au moment des
attentats que ce soit en janvier
ou en novembre depuis qu'il a été à la
hauteur et avec le souci
comme le disait pascal boniface de
rassembler de tenir le pays et dans un
an dans une réalité démocratique et donc
voilà donc c'est un peu la dualité 5 en
temps normal mais il a été et c'est
normal c'est exactement les français
vont françois hollande est quelqu'un qui
est personnellement sympathique il n'est
pas arrogant il n'est pas qu'à sang etc
mais les français prennent un peu de
régalien et donc c'est vrai que le livre
passer son temps avec des gens lisses
pour raconter des secrets d'état en plus
là du coup il y a dans le quotidien un
manque de distance et de deux fonctions
du costume de président qui doit certes
être près du peuple qui ne voient peut
plus être en dehors et qui ne peut plus
être un monarque comme auparavant même
si françois hollande comme d'autres us à
courre enfin bon ça c'est des phénomènes
auxquels je pense et mâcon va être
confronté au lit déjà on sentait
d'ailleurs bon mais il peut être que on
attendait un peu autre chose on est un
peu une chose d'un président que du
camarade sympathique qui est toujours
disponible il a voulu marquer une
rupture et lyon ce clic en partie ça
explique en partie c'est-à-dire la
volonté de france hollande d'apparaître
comme l'antithèse de nicolas sarkozy est
très frappante au début de son mandat
on a le sentiment même que dans ses
décisions et aux systématiquement
prendre le contre-pied de nicolas
sarkozy mais au fond tout les deux
françois hollande et nicolas sarkozy on
verra pour emmanuel macron ils sont les
contemporains d'une transformation du
rôle et de la communication du rôle
exécutif et on voit que tout le monde
cherche un point d'équilibré une bonne
mesure entre l'ancien style
effectivement très dans le magistère
dans le noir chic et puis en même temps
ne pas tomber dans le président de la
république est une sorte de deux gros
premier ministre de super premier
ministre on voit qu'ils ont du mal tous
les deux les deux précédents précise
président a trouvé le rôle parce que
nicolas sarkozy aussi avec beaucoup de
difficultés avec l'incarnation du rôle
présidentiel
et pour emmanuel macron on peut se poser
des questions on commence à apercevoir
dans sa communication aussi peut-être
aussi des éléments d'incertitude sur ce
rôle quand on le voit est bien traversé
la cour du louvre l'esplanade du louvre
là aussi on voit qu'ils une volonté de
fer dans le magistère dans le solennel
et en même temps on sent bien que
quelque part c'est c'est ambigu c'est
une communication qui apparaît presque
surdimensionné pour l'événement 2 2
dimanche soir dont qu'ils sont tout
simplement des contemporains d'une
transformation très important du rapport
des citoyens au pouvoir qui n'est plus à
des années lumière effectivement les
réseaux sociaux etc
ils se cherchent tous je suis en partie
d'accord est un lycée qui a pris
contre-pied france hollande a pris le
contre-pied nicolas sarkozy notamment
avec la présence en mal qui est aussi un
concept dans l'opposition à dominique
strauss kahn à la base mais il a jamais
en fait défini ce qui était la
présidence normale la wii il aurait pu
effectivement partir de ce concept là
qui était un concept fort de campagne
qui avait montré buire sans doute en
partie à sa victoire sans définir et en
fait il l'a réduit à des artifices comme
prendre le train plutôt que l'avion
prendre la voiture pour les actuels
plutôt que l'avion où passait ses
vacances ses premières vacances on voit
ces photos dans la presse people de lui
en maillot de bain avec sa compagne dont
celle qui n'a jamais vraiment défini on
vient ce fil rouge cette narration et
emmanuel macron a tenté de le faire mais
on verra si pourri ne sera pas
prisonnier lui aussi de ses concepts de
campagne en disant je serai un président
qui préside je laisserais mon chris
collins gouverner elle revient en fait à
l'esprit la vème république avec un
petit peu de hauteur et on voit bien que
l'événement du louvre était aussi pour
montrer justement la hauteur de la
présidence de répliques en tout cas ce
qu'elle devrait avoir comme auteur alors
en difficulté sur le plan national
françois hollande a en revanche redorer
son blason sur la scène internationale
s'il a su restaurer la crédibilité de la
france et de son armée n'a peut-être pas
su définir de véritables cap notamment
résoudre la crise en syrie flora sauvage
la signature de l'accord de paris à
l'issue de la coop 21 est un succès du
quinquennat de françois hollande
il réalise l'impensable mettre d'accord
195 délégations étrangères
le 12 décembre 2015 le premier texte
universel contraignant sur le climat est
signé même si donald trump a menacé de
se retirer de l'accord de paris la coop
21 restera une réussite
personnelle pour le chef de l'état
français car il s'agissait d'un pari
risqué
autre fait marquant du quinquennat les
opérations extérieures assure à françois
hollande
une réputation de chef de guerre janvier
2013 des colonnes de djihadistes menace
bamako ils lancent l'opération serval au
mali qui mettra fin à cette offensive et
c'est en héros qu'il est accueilli à
bamako la capitale malienne
un mois plus tard
[Applaudissements]
en centrafrique françois hollande lance
l'opération sogaris en décembre 2013
pour mettre un terme aux violences
intercommunautaires
concernant l'europe son bilan est plus
mitigé sur le dossier grec
il a su s'imposer entre le rigorisme de
berlin et la politique anti austérité
d'athènes mais le couple franco allemand
n'a pas toujours été au beau fixe sur la
gestion de la crise migratoire
enfin le grand échec de la politique
étrangère du quinquennat restera la
syrie françois hollande n'a pas réussi à
imposer la voix de la france dans la
résolution de ce conflit
je continue néanmoins de regretter je le
dis devant vous que la communauté
internationale n'ait pas agi en temps
voulu pour faire cesser les massacres
ont suivi après l'échec de
l'intervention internationale avortée
avec le renoncement de washington paris
a peu à peu été écartée du dossier
syrien
aujourd'hui la france pèse peu au
moyen-orient pascal boniface au françois
hollande chef de guerre c'est là
peut-être qu'il s'est le plus révélé ça
ce qu'on vous dit rien oui effectivement
alain valu le mentionnait tout à l'heure
il a su prendre une décision rapide pour
interdire au mali qui a été efficace les
américains eux mêmes été bluffé en
disant nous on n'aurait pas pu agir dans
des circonstances aussi rapide et donc
l'opération au mali c'est l'exemple même
d'opération militaire réussie alors que
la plupart des autres opérations
militaires occidentales en afrique ou
ailleurs ont échoué parce qu'il y avait
un consensus international qui avait une
demande du pays qu' il y avait surtout
le jour d'après il y avait un objectif
politique c'est l'exemple inverse de la
libye on a dit on veut de la
communication et on ne pense pas après
pour le bilan international il ya quand
même des réussites la coop 21 dont on a
parlé intervention mali il faut pas
oublier les accords de minsk parce qu'il
n'a pas tout à fait rompu avec la russie
alors qu'on lui demandait de dire non
quand même pas recevoir
poutine aux commémorations du 100e
anniversaire du débarquement
mais c'est peut-être la plus que jamais
qu'il a manqué un récit que dans pour
les pays extérieurs on se demande un peu
où est la france et pragmatiquement du
coup par coup
c'est bien mais il n'a pas su incarner
la fait enfin lorsqu'on apprend que la
nsa espionne libon ses balles et on
continue quand même il n'a pas su temps
en temps parce qu'il n'est pas clivant
faire les gestes que aussi bien
de gaulle mitterrand et chirac ont fait
en leur temps de taper du poing sur la
table et de dire aussi bien aux
américains aux autres et bien il faut
faire cela et puis ils m'ont quand même
aussi là une grosse trahison des
engagements
la non reconnaissance de la palestine
lorsque c'est un engagement fort du
début de son quinquennat qu'il n'a pas
fait largement pour les raisons de
politique intérieure mais et qui du coup
un peu terni le prestige de la france
dans cette région parce que la france
était depuis de gaulle depuis mitterrand
l'avocat de cette cause donc c'est un
bilan qui est très contrastée mais qui
surtout fait que comme il n'a pas
illustré d'un récit même il n'a pas su
finalement de temps en temps prendre le
taureau par les cornes et dire aux
américains non c'est pas possible ou ou
d'autres comme l'ont fait en leur temps
ses prédécesseurs et bien la visibilité
de la france n'est pas terminé il ya
toujours une attente mais elle s'est
légèrement estompées
malgré quelques succès remarquable nora
m'a dit nous a également rejoint sur ce
plateau bonsoir mourra spéciales et des
questions européennes pour public sénat
on a parlé du bilan de françois hollande
sur le plan international à au quel
bilan vous dressez vous sur le plan
européen justement autant dire delphine
que c'est un bilan en 2000 en
demi-teinte pardon en 2012 on se
souvient lui président il avait promis
de réformer l'europe remettent de la
croissance et de l'emploi
dans cette europe osterrieth r autant
dire que sur ce premier chantier il n'a
pas du tout aboutit on se souvient du
traité budgétaires européens négocient
en pleine crise de l'euro par nicolas
sarkozy qui posait le principe d'un
retour à l'équilibré des finances
publiques qui a été adopté à la virgule
près par le parlement français est donc
à l'image de ce péché originel un du tsc
j'ai comme on l'appelle au le françois
hollande et les questions européennes le
bilan est plutôt maigre il a échoué à
réorienter l'europe que je vous disais
sur la croissance il a échoué dans
l'approfondissement de la zone euro il a
échoué dans son projet de proposer des
'eurobonds' des obligations un des
heureux obligations afin de mutualiser
les dettes souveraines européennes il a
échoué à renouer le lien entre les
français et l'union européenne 1 sur 2 1
pour rappel à voter pour des partis
eurosceptiques voir europhobe au premier
tour de cette présidentielle
un lien qu'il a toujours eu lui même du
mal à définir sachant qu' il était
premier secrétaire du parti socialiste
en 2005 alors que le référendum sur la
constitution européenne a déchiré son
parti
sa gestion tiède aussi de la crise des
réfugiés a été particulièrement
critiquée notamment le double discours
vis-à-vis de berlin et d'angela merkel
qui a pris en charge seul la gestion de
la crise et qui a pris en charge seul
l'accord qui a été négocié avec la
turquie avec l'aide de la commission
européenne qui a permis de tarir un
petit peu ce flux également son
incapacité à tenir ses engagements
budgétaires le dogme et des 3% certains
l'appellent le dogme et les 3% qui n'a
rien arrangé
françois hollande là dessus a braqué les
allemands aura trahi ce contrat de
confiance dans ce couple formé par
berlin et paris une confiance qui a été
difficilement possible à renouer le seul
moment où il a été incapable en fait de
recréer ce lien
c'est après les attentats de charlie
hebdo et de l'hyper cacher donc le 11
janvier 2005 avec cette photo dont on se
souvient tous 1,7 et paul posée par
angela merkel sur donc françois hollande
à l'aune de cette manifestation happy
demant lui reconnaît aussi quelques
victoires
effectivement la victoire on en parlait
tout à l'heure le dossier ukrainien et
le dossier grec le dossier ukrainien il
a permis par ses talents de négociateur
grâce aussi à un gala merkel de créer ce
lien et d'éviter l'escaladé en fait dans
le dossier ukrainien après l'annexion de
la crimée et sur la grèce il a évité
clairement ingres excite en allant aider
en fait alexis tsipras ce qui avait
beaucoup de difficulté à discuter avec
leurs groupes et notamment avec
l'orthodoxe wolfgang schauble le
ministre des finances allemand celui en
somme qui en parle le mieux finalement
c'est pierre moscovici sont en service
de l'économie et actuelle commissaire
européen aux finances il le qualifie
avec une pointe de déception hollande
n'a pas été moteur en europe en gros il
reste plutôt l'image d'un gestionnaire à
défaut d'un visionnaire d'achille poète
alain bergounioux vous avez eue avec
grâce
quelques nuances parce que bon on
parlait tout à l'heure d'un symbole fort
il restera dans l'histoire le symbole de
janvier 2015 mais on voyait des images
voilà alors évidemment un symbole un peu
imposée mais est quand même extrêmement
fort ensuite c'est tout le débat sur la
question européenne
parce que et c'est sévère c'est vrai en
europe comme nationalement si lille a
adopté une démarche pragmatique parce
que il n'a pas tenu ses engagements des
trois pour cent parce qu'il ne voulait
pas les tenir et il a obtenu je le redis
j'avais dit en début d'émission et il a
obtenu l'allemagne une tolérance pour ça
mais en même temps il fallait signer le
traité et en même temps on ne peut pas
dire qu'il ne s'est rien passé en europe
dans ces cinq ans parce que je me
souviens des débats qui pouvait y avoir
dans les années 2000 il fallait que la
banque centrale européenne 16,2 de
s'occuper uniquement de l'inflation la
banque centrale européenne a joué un
rôle majeur pour pour éviter la crise et
à une politique qu on aurait rêvé yahia
disant de ce point de vue il ya eu
l'union bank est atteint il ya des
choses qui se sont passées en europe
mais et un françois hollande a estimé à
tort ou à raison
le débat continuera puis il y aura des
pièces d'archivés témoignages que il la
france n'avait pas le rapport de force
pour faire bouger l'europe seul et c'est
vrai qu'il avait quand même pas eu et
qui n'avait pas beaucoup d'alliés et le
socialisme européens étaient divisés sur
cette question là une action efficace
convenable en europe oui puis moyens
manquaient d'allier effectivement les
italiens 2 sur lequel il s'appuie au
tout départ ont eu une crise
gouvernementale messieurs je voulais
revenir d'un mot sur la syrie qui a été
volé dans un reportage
parce que l'accusation de dire c'est la
france qui n'a pas non la france n'a pas
réussi à résoudre la crise syrienne
pas plus que la russie pas plus que les
états unis peu puisque l'iran pas plus
qu'aucun autre pays et est donc il est
injuste de critiquer uniquement la
france et françois hollande par contre
moi je n'achète pas le discours qui est
le discours reconstruit de françois
hollande et du gouvernement ne dira si
on vous écoute et en septembre 2013 ont
été bombardés qui auraient été réglés
non on aurait été dans une situation
catastrophique parce que quand on est
membre permanent
du conseil de sécurité dans sa pelle la
france on se lance pas dans une guerre
sans feu vert du conseil de suivi n'est
donc heureusement qu'on l'a pas fait et
là on voit bien qu'il ya une tentation
de faire du storytelling sur le fait
si on vous écoutait à l'époque la crise
syrienne aurait été réglé c'est faut
donc qu'il est injuste de l'attaqué ne
pas l'avoir réglée il serait injuste de
dire que si on a écouté la france à la à
l'été 2013 la paix serait arrivé en
cible on a évoqué quand même s'il a
commenté en soit c'était un succès pour
peut-être masquer les erreurs de
communication du président là il a quand
même capitaliser sur son image à cette
occasion oui les sort quand même la
place à laurent fabius qui était lui le
maître d'oeuvre de la cap 21
mais c'est que la tenue de ce sommet
international très important pour
réchauffement climatique 20 contre le
réchauffement climatique
quelques semaines après l'attentât quand
même 2 novembre 2015 était un grand défi
pour la france et françois hollande a
quand même réussi à d'autres événements
à deux occasions aussi comme les
commémorations du débarquement à réunir
tous ces chefs d'état et de gouvernement
dans une pièce pour une belle photo de
famille mais ça reste quand même des
images des symboles et c'est pas une
action de fond qu'il a réussi à mener là
c'est même plus qu'un symbole la
convention y compris quand même plus
sincères en termes de causer la vérité
c'est bien sûr sur les questions
européennes je pense qu'effectivement le
lien des français avec l'europe ne c'est
parti c'est qu'un cours du mandat de mme
de françois hollande et mais c'est une
histoire qui est parti bien avant
françois hollande et qui ne s'est pas
encore arrêté puisqu'on vient de voir
dans l'élection de d'emmanuel macron à
quel point la question de l'europe il
est maintenant sur la table et à l'être
sans aucun doute redébattu ya un conflit
d'interprétation dans la société
française et on n'est plus du tout
aujourd'hui dans un sorte d'opposition
frontale entre les pro et les anti
européens
on est plutôt une bataille notre habitat
sur le sens de l'europe la direction
l'europe au profit de qui pour faire
quoi et une véritable de batailles
d'interprétation sur cette question à
l'intérieur de la gauche à l'inter de la
droite aussi mal un terreau de la gauche
c'est une bataille d'interprétation qui
n'a pas encore dit son dernier mot
oui le team ans et c'était pourtant il
c'est un européen convaincu mais il n'a
pas su renouer ce fils et
l'euroscepticisme
l'hostilité ou là lol nan et station la
protestation par on voit bien les scores
quoi électoraux ils n'ont pas bougé d'un
iota voir ils se sont donc ils ont
augmenté au cours du quinquennat 30
secondes j'aurais juste vous rappeler
cette phrase de françois hollande il a
prononcé lui-même lors d'un discours au
théâtre du rond point pour les 80 ans du
front populaire
c'est la tragédie de lagos au pouvoir ça
peut résumer le quinquennat transforme
en bas il ya toujours eu un rapport
difficile de la gauche au pouvoir parce
qu'on attend plus de la gauche qui doit
transformer que de la droite qui veut
conserver
donc la gauche déçoit toujours parce que
elle va jamais assez loin dans la
transformation
et quand les ré la gauche de la gauche
arrive au pouvoir comme on l'a vu en
grèce elle éprouve les contradictions du
pouvoir donc c'est ça le point là
historiquement à vérifier depuis des
décennies merci beaucoup alain
bergounioux merci pascal boniface merci
zied jebrane merci pour nos autres à sa
merci à vous nora on va parler et bien
maintenant de l'actualité c'est au sénat
cette éventualité d'un report des
élections sénatoriales puisque elles
sont normalement prévues le 24 septembre
prochain et elle pourrait être reportée
d'un an
l'objectif c'est de rendre effectives
rapidement la réforme du nombre de
parlementaires les explications de
jambes ravie elle n'est pas en marche
elle court la rumeur sur un possible
report des élections sénatoriales
prévues en septembre prochain
parti d'un article du bulletin quotidien
elle circule désormais jusqu'au plus
haut sommet de l'état comme le confirme
certains élus beaucoup en parler compris
des ministres dont je tairai le nom qui
en ont parlé hier je le sais puisque
l'un d'entre eux m'a appelé pour me
parler avant le conseil des ministres
donc c'est un sujet qui semble être
selon les échos que j'ai actée par le
président de la république
la moitié de la chambre haute devait
être concernés soit 170 sénateurs mais
emmanuel macron envisagerait de
repousser leur mandat d'un an pour faire
passer la loi sur la diminution du
nombre de parlementaires n'y a pas
d'autre solution que de reporter les
sénatoriales de 2007 à 2010 8,7 une
solution pour vous oui j'y suis très
favorable j'ai d'ailleurs un peu
travaillé sur le sujet afin de préparer
ce texte de loi pour un d'une diminution
générale de tous les sénateurs en 2021
mais à moins de cinq mois de cette
échéance
et oral est ce possible sans le
souhaitait le président du sénat laisse
la porte ouverte et doit s'entretenir de
ce sujet avec emmanuel macron ce
week-end moi je suis par nature pour le
respect des règles en cours
en démocratie ça n'est pas semble-t-il
juridiquement impossible
il reste encore à examiner quelques
aspects constitutionnels la décision
quelle qu'elle soit doit être rapidement
acté car les sénateurs devront pour
valider ce report voter une loi
organique et le conseil constitutionnel
se prononcer et pour comprendre les
enjeux de ce report éventuel des
élections sénatoriales à jean philippe
derosier professeur de droit
constitutionnel est notre invité il
répond aux questions de tam tran huy le
face à face s'est tout de suite
[Musique]
jean philippe derosier bonsoir bonsoir
alors est ce que un report des élections
sénatoriales de 2017 à 2018 serait selon
vous une bonne chose l'objectif affiché
par en marche c'est de pouvoir passer sa
loi organique notamment diminuerait le
nombre de parlementaires avant ces
élections je sais pas si c'est une bonne
chose ou une mauvaise chose mais ça me
semble complexe pour un triple point de
vue pratique politique et
constitutionnelle d'un point de vue
pratique cela ne peut se faire vous
l'avez dit que par l'adoption d'une loi
organique et il n'est pas question
d'adopter une loi organique avant
l'élection clé avant les élections
législatives
donc cela veut dire que le texte ne
pourrait arriver sur le bureau du
parlement qu' à compter de la fin du
mois de juin et par conséquent ils ne
pourraient pas être adopté avant la fin
du mois de juillet les délais sont très
courts et donc les délais sont
extrêmement en prenant le train les
élections sont prévues pour le 24
septembre
c'est bien que la loi ne serait
promulguée pas moins de deux mois avant
les élections elles-mêmes et prévoir
moins de deux mois avant le report d'une
élection quelle qu'elle soit et en
particulier les sénatoriales me semble
quelque peu délicat donc il faudrait
agir très vite
et ce n'est peut-être pas là la priorité
immédiate à laquelle doit se livrer à un
président élu au regard de l'opinion
publique et de son électorat
d'ailleurs l'un d'eux hier de nager
déjà envoyé les convocations aux
conseillers municipaux soit la quasi
totalité des gens c'est exactement ça
c'est s'éteint le point le problème
constitutionnel que j'évoquerai ensuite
sur le plan politique le message qui est
renvoyée à de la part d'un président qui
veut rénover la vie politique c'est
attendez on va rénover mais on va
proroger d'un an le mandat de ceux qui
sont déjà élus ça ne me semble pas être
symboliquement vraiment la meilleure
mesure et on va dire aussi repoussé d'un
an l'application du non-cumul des
mandats et bien pour les sénateurs c'est
cela que ça voudrait dire parce que
normalement ça s'applique au sénat
renouvelée en 2017 et il y aurait là
effectivement une petite difficulté
juridique qui peut être facilement
résolu il suffit que la loi tranche de
savoir s'il s'applique au 1er septembre
ou si ça s'applique à compter du
renouvellement du prochain
renouvellement du sénat
mais effectivement ça pourrait prorogé
vraisemblablement sa prorogerait
également cette application signal 7
soit la nouvelle mort exactement va
aussi à l'encontre du renouvellement et
surtout d'un point de vue
constitutionnel
il y à me semble-t-il un certain nombre
de difficultés vous l'avez souligné
les convocations des grands électeurs
sont déjà partis la campagne pour les
élections sénatoriales ce n'est pas
officiellement lancée a tout de même
débuté parce que notamment tous les
frais de campagne sont déjà répertoriés
ils sont répertoriés depuis le 1er mars
lire six mois avant l'élection
sénatoriale elle même et donc si c'est
reporté ça veut dire que tout ce qui a
été engagé jusqu'à présent est annulée
est ce qu'on leur porte sur le compte
suivant est ce que au contraire on
efface tout et on recommence sa
soulèverait une certaine inégalité
saison il est j'y comme situation
et je ne suis pas certain que le conseil
constitutionnel qui apprécient qui devra
apprécier cette loi organique parce que
il est obligé de contrôler les lois
organiques valide le fait que à moins de
deux mois on reporte une élection le
conseil constitutionnel accepte la
prorogation des mandats pour des raisons
d'intérêt général et signalent toujours
et à juste titre qu'il n'a pas un
pouvoir d'appréciation appréciation
identique à celui du parlement et qu'il
n'est pas là pour dire si la solution
envisagée par le parlement pourrait plus
être
trouvé par une autre voie néanmoins il
s'assure que l'objectif poursuivi n'est
pas manifestement inappropriées d'un
point de vue constitutionnel et là étant
donné que la campagne est déjà un petit
peu engagés et que visiblement l'intérêt
général c'est simplement la réduction du
nombre de sénateurs
ça n'a pas de conséquence réel sur la
vie démocratique du pays
d'autant plus que si l'on réduit
immédiatement le nombre de sénateurs
parce que c'est pour cela que l'on
voudrait reporter les sénatoriales c'est
pour appliquer dès septembre ou plus
exactement des l'élection du prochain
sénat la réduction du nombre de
sénateurs
et bien si on le fait dès à présent cela
voudrait dire que il y aurait un net
décalage entre le nombre de sénateurs et
le nombre de députés à l'assemblée
nationale
lesquels ne serait réduit dans leur
nombre a priori que d'ici cinq ans sauf
dissolution qui pourrait être prononcé
par le président de la république
il y aurait aussi un décalage au sein
même du sénat entre les personnes qui
auraient été renouvelé cette fois-ci et
celles qui sont renouvelés trois ans
plus tard
oui alors ça problèmes que cela serait
aussi un problème qui me paraît être en
réalité un faux problème parce que à
partir du moment où l'on acte le fait
que l'on veut réduire le nombre de
sénateurs
il y aura nécessairement une période
transitoire où un randy sion on peut
envisager un renouvellement intégral la
loi organique peut absolument tout
décider il n'est pas prévu dans la
constitution que le sénat doivent se
renouveler par moitié tous les trois ans
ou quoi aux caisses la constitution
impose simplement un nombre maximum de
sénateurs 348 et qu'il soit élu au
suffrage universel indirect
elle ne fixe pas la durée du mandat ne
fixe pas le mode de renouvellement ni le
mode de scrutin
mais étant donné que il a toujours été
renouvelée ainsi que le sénat ait dit
d'une assemblée permanente justement
parce qu'il se renouvelle par moitié
je ne suis pas certain que le choix se
portent effectivement sur un
renouvellement intégral et d'un point de
vue constitutionnel je ne pense pas que
ça pose un une réelle difficulté qu'il y
ait pendant une période transitoire des
sénateurs enfin une disparité
au niveau de la représentativité des
dessinateurs un faux problème donc pour
vous là on va également parlé du
programme d' emmanuel macron en matière
de renouvellement des institutions jean
philippe derosier
il promet une grande loi sur la
moralisation de la vie publique 1 ça
serait et sa première loi est ce qu'on
peut considérer que c'est une réponse
aussi à tout ce climat des affaires qui
a émaillé la campagne
alors je ne sais pas si c'est une
réponse ce que je vois ce que je crois
c'est qu'il ya une attente de la part
des électeurs si une attente sur ce
sujet ce climat sur cette volonté de
moraliser la vie politique on disait que
pour l'opposition actuelle pour les
républicains pour la droite
c'était une élection imperdable et elle
a néanmoins réussi à la perdre alors
quelles en sont les causes exactes cela
on pourra s'y pencher peut-être d'ici
quelques années
mais le fait est que les affaires que
qui ont été révélées à l'égard de
françois fillon ont certainement leur
part de cause dans ce résultat final est
donc c'est bien que les français veulent
sanctionner certaines attitudes et donc
il y à une attente de leur côté et par
conséquent emmanuel macron s'est engagé
à faire une réforme sur la moralisation
de la vie publique est effectivement est
ce une réponse seulement à ces affaires
de la campagne est ce une réponse plus
générale sur la vie publique telle qu'on
l'a pu la voir peut-être mort du dernier
quinquennat ou même au delà
cela peut-être que ça ressortira dans
les débats d'abord cette loi prévoit que
les détenteurs de casier judiciaire ne
pourront plus se présenter ça étonne
presque que ce soit possible aujourd'hui
oui alors détenir un casier judiciaire
cela signifie que l'on a été condamné
pour une quelques cause que ce soit ce
ne sont pas seulement les meurtriers ou
les violeurs qui détiennent un casier
judiciaire mais qu' on n'a été condamné
que on a purgé sa peine et que donc on
est quittes vis-à-vis de la société par
rapport à l'infraction que l'on a
commises et donc effectivement c'est
pour cela que
lorsque le casier n'est pas vierge mais
que l'on a effectivement purgé sa peine
et que si on était inéligible on est
redevenu éligible on peut à nouveau se
présenter à une élection et notamment
l'élection ça me paraît une bonne chose
ce casier judiciaire vierge
oui parce que alors il faut on peut pas
on n'a pas le temps de rentrer dans le
détail du casier judiciaire mais il ya
différentes strates dans le dans le
casier judiciaire est celui qui doit
être vierge eux c'est le b2c vers le
bulletin numéro deux du casier
judiciaire qui est celui qui détient un
certain nombre d'informations mais pas
toutes
et effectivement c'est une preuve de
moralisation et ils ont il faut savoir
qu'au bout d'un certain temps que l'on a
purgé sa peine
le casier judiciaire s'efface que donc
on ne va pas traîner comme un fardeau
tout au long de sa vie une erreur de
jeunesse ou un élément que l'on a pu
commettre par le passé autre mesure
importante dans les activités de conseil
seront proscrites pour les élus est ce
que cette mesure va assez loin pour
éviter les conflits d'intérêts car c'est
bien là l'objectif c'est d'une première
étape
mais il faut regarder le problème dans
son ensemble et l'on souhaite de plus en
plus avoir des élus qui souhaitent ligne
qu'il fasse pour être une probité ça
concerne le point précédent et qui se
consacre pleinement aux mandats dont ils
sont investis et s'était notamment
l'idée de la limitation du cumul des
mandats pour avoir des parlementaires à
plein temps si telle est l'idée alors il
faut les empêcher de mener quelques
autres vie professionnelle que ce soit
pendant la durée de leur mandat
sauf que cela pose un autre problème qui
est ensuite le retour à la vie non
politique je ne veux pas dire la vie
civile parce que pour moi la vie
politique est une vie civile
mais au delà en tout cas un retour est
stationné du courlis donc ça pose la
question du statut de l'élu très
exactement
d'autant plus si l'on veut limiter dans
le temps le nombre de mandats ce qui
veut dire qu'au bout d'un certain nombre
d'années on va être contraint de revenir
à sa vie professionnelle d'avant est
évidemment au bout de cinq dix ou quinze
ans eh bien les techniques ont évolué la
profession a pu changer et quelqu'un qui
sait consacrer à plein temps à sa vie
d'élu n'a plus forcément connaissance
de sa profession et n'est plus
concurrentielle sur le marché et donc il
faut trouver des moyens il faut y
réfléchir et ça doit être être
concomitant à cette réflexion sur
effectivement le l'activité de conseil
qui est une première étape mais qui
devrait aller plus loin à mon avis merci
merci beaucoup jean-philippe de rezé
d'avoir répondu à nos questions sur
notamment cette vaste loi de
moralisation de la vie publique qui
comporte bien d'autres points bien
entendu merci
c'est la fin de cette édition merci à
vous de l'avoir suivi à 22h sonia
mabrouk et ses invités quant à moi je
vous donne rendez-vous lundi pour un
nouvelle édition de politique 360
nous vous rendez vous sur public ce
match ce sera à 18h bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]
et